Jaclyn Hill is back on her weight loss
Journey with a little life update video
and let's just say we've got a lot to
unpack hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey also a big reminder that I am
not a therapist or a substance abuse
expert but I'll be speaking from the
perspective as a registered dietitian
and if you are not already subscribed
here hit that subscribe button and
follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen okay so if
you missed my most recent video on
Jaclyn's Wellness Saga you can check
that out right here where Jacqueline was
really focusing on her mental health and
also reducing her Reliance on alcohol
but let's take a look at what Jaclyn's
been up to and where she's currently at
on her Wellness Journey today I'm going
to be a bride in nine months and I want
to look my absolute best I feel so
motivated and so excited to take care of
myself so first things first a big
congratulations are in order for Jaclyn
and Jordan who who got engaged back in
December 2021 and while working towards
an important occasion like a wedding can
certainly be a powerful motivator to
engage in healthy lifestyle behaviors My
Hope Is that Jacqueline can do so from a
place of self-care and in a way that is
sustainable long term there's really no
point in starving yourself to fit into a
dress only to gain the weight
immediately back and then some when you
get under the honeymoon this is exactly
how people end up yo-yo dieting or
weight cycling all their lives basically
they go too hard too fast rebound repeat
planning a wedding is already a really
stressful time and we add on a strict
diet and potential alcohol use both of
which have been shown to further
increase our stress hormone cortisol it
can actually make it even harder to lose
weight long story short chronically
elevated levels of cortisol are
consistently associated with increased
appetite and weight gain particularly
the more metabolically dangerous
visceral fat around our belly so if
weight loss is the goal I hope that she
can have of realistic and safe
expectations managing the root cause for
alcohol use in emotional eating is also
going to be pivotal to long-term success
so let's take a look at how therapy has
been going I have done over 60 sessions
of neurofeedback my anxiety went from a
10 the last like five six months to A2
my anxiety is at Bay and I'm able to
finally live my life be happy and enjoy
little things I'm very proud of how far
I have come that is a lot of therapy I
mean amazing good for her that's such an
accomplishment that takes a lot a lot of
work with better anxiety Baseline levels
and more supportive coping strategies in
place I feel really strongly that she'll
be in a better place to lose and keep
the weight that she's trying to lose off
research on binge eating disorders
suggests that anxiety is one of the key
emotions associated with overeating and
there's actually a number of really
interesting theories on why this is so
the Escape Theory suggests that chronic
dieters like Jacqueline are more
vulnerable to to negative self-belief
which results in higher anxiety levels
that need to be escaped from with
concrete stimuli like food another
theory suggests that eating serves as a
trade-off to temporarily reduce the
negative experience of anxiety and even
though the individual often feels guilty
or disappointed after the binge in that
particular moment they feel that the
trade-off is worth it we've seen this in
the past with Jaclyn as she expressed
her own self-loathing for cheating on
her diet I'm literally sitting here
eating pizza this is I feel like the
world's biggest failure as far as my
journey goes because I feel like I'm
just kind of right back to the past in
the sense of my face is like getting
bigger again I'm eating foods that cause
inflammation I am so stressed out with
what's going on in my business and I'm
just so scared now I'm not suggesting
that Jaclyn has an eating disorder at
all but we do tend to see these same
behaviors in the general population who
are engaging in even occasional
overeating episodes I've been
consistently working out for the most
part but haven't been pushed pushing
myself consistently you know what I mean
so I consistently like walking you know
just like because for me I'm like I need
to keep my body moving so it sounds like
Jaclyn is focusing more on the process
of movement and exercise rather than the
outcome in other words rather than
pushing her body through strenuous
exercise strictly as a means to lose
weight fast she's begun to focus on how
moving her body actually feels
and by switching our mindset towards
physical activity from being goal driven
to Purpose Driven we can start to tune
into what types of exercises actually
feel good to our body regardless of the
outcome on the scale this helps us tune
into other non-weight related outcomes
like improved mood energy levels
digestion Sleep Quality strength
endurance flexibility Etc and focusing
on these benefits can help us push
through the frustrating plateaus when we
are trying to lose weight and when I
first started this whole fitness journey
I was 183 pounds now I'm literally
sitting at 171 like I have I don't gain
or lose so depending on how much effort
it's taking Jaclyn to maintain this
number it's very possible that 171
pounds is Jaclyn's kind of natural set
point weight basically your set point is
a genetically determined weight range
where your body functions optimally and
while there really isn't any scientific
way to know definitively that you're in
the zone there are some key indicators
so some quick questions to ask yourself
are are you getting regular periods are
you eating in response to your hunger
and fullness cues are you able to go
through your day not constantly thinking
about food are you moving your body in
ways that feel good rather than as
punishment are you eating foods that you
enjoy in a mouse that actually feel good
to your body if you answered yes to all
the above and your weight has basically
stabilized then this could be an
indication that you're within your set
point range whether or not you can
change your set point range is
definitely Up For Debate however there
is a lot of evidence to suggest that
dramatically changing your set point
weight can be very difficult and this is
because when we push our bodies outside
of it's like 10 to 20 pound range that
it prefers our body throws in a bunch of
compensatory mechanisms to remedy the
problem so our hunger hormone ghrelin
increases we subconsciously move less we
obsessively think about food and we see
shifts in our metabolic rate this isn't
our body failing us it's actually just
trying to Keep Us Alive my game plan is
I have reached out to friends of mine
that have successfully lost weight built
muscle just looking fit feeling great
and I've asked them what it is that
they're doing and I'm going to listen to
them and myself and my body and I know
what works and what has worked for me in
the past and I'm going to give it my all
for the next six to eight weeks and if I
don't see any differences in six to
eight weeks then I'm going to then hire
a nutritionist and a personal trainer I
mean fine no harm in hearing your
friends though but the experience of any
singular person is not going to give us
any insight into what may work for you
take intermittent fasting for example we
have evidence that some people will lose
weight while other people will gain
weight while trying to intermittently
fast so I would strongly suggest
skipping the anecdotes and going
straight to individualized professional
support this my mindset I look back at
those videos and I kind of cringe
because it's like I know everyone has to
go through the process but I'm like oh
my God girl calm down like the fact that
I was like fluctuating in weight so much
and I wouldn't eat like one carb for
like six or seven days and then I would
go to my favorite restaurant and I would
probably eat like 2 000 calories minimum
of just carbs and fried food that my
friends is what we call the binge
restrict cycle and our girl Jacqueline
has honestly been on that roller coaster
for a really long time acknowledging
this pattern is a really great first
step making yourself accountable to all
of her fans might also help as well but
this is going to be an all hands on deck
exercise so again getting a qualified
professional on board would really be
key I'm gonna just eat clean I'm not
gonna eat late at night I'm gonna snack
minimally only on healthy foods I'm
going to use my friend's advice oh this
feels like classic Jaclyn talk one
minute she says something that sounds
like empowering and inspiring and then
over time it kind of slowly morphs into
diet culture it sounds to me like we're
back in a restrictive mindset which is
ultimately the number one predictor of a
binge as for her diet plans first of all
cleaning is a first so yeah please can
we stop moralizing food number two with
the late night snacking we do have some
research to suggest that there are some
metabolic benefits to front loading our
calories earlier on in the day to line
with our circadian rhythm since our
bodies are more insulin sensitive in the
morning but that's not generally why
people who snack a lot late into the
night are more likely to gain weight
it's more likely that we're just going
to choose chips over carrots at 10 pm
when we're over tired we're over hungry
or we're more likely to eat emotionally
but purposefully restricting Foods at
night on nights that we may be
legitimately hungry is either a setup
from night binge or a really really bad
night's sleep and poor Sleep Quality can
also impact weight loss by increasing
our hunger hormones and our appetite
ditto with the snacking rule like
friends let's get something straight
snacks aren't bad you know I like Snack
Pack why can't you just give me a snack
pack snacks don't inherently make you
gain weight assuming that they fit into
your caloric budget for the day so
rather than rules that focus on what we
need to take away which ultimately Keeps
Us trapped in scarcity mentality I would
want to focus on what foods we can add
building meals and snacks that are
balanced with protein fiber and fat can
help us effortlessly curb late night or
midday snacking without the need to set
up a bunch of these restrictive rules
that our body and mind just wants to
break additive not restrictive that's
the key to sustainable weight loss when
managing a complicated relationship with
food and it's like it's not like I need
this all to get smaller but I need to
get more toned I need to get more fit
for me to feel the confidence that I
want to feel and I think that that
should be praised you know what I'm
saying like if you're unhappy with your
body then do what you need to do to
change it it's not about the way you
look it truly is about the way you feel
that's what it comes down to I think
it's totally understandable to have
aesthetic goals they're all personal to
us and our unique Journey so I don't
think that Jacqueline necessarily needs
to defend her desire to change her body
if she thinks that it'll make her feel
better or more confident but any
aesthetic changes should ultimately come
from a place of self-care and respect
for our body rather than from a place of
self-control and Punishment in other
words we shouldn't be pushing ourselves
through grueling workout routines that
we hate just so we can drop a few pounds
or work out harder to burn off our meals
respecting your body is imperative to
long-term sustainable Behavior change
even if the ultimate goal is to change
the way your body looks so if Jacqueline
can get to a place where she is engaging
in physical activity that feels good
nourishing her body Optimum family and
feeling her most confident self along
the way then I am totally here for it I
you know that today is day one it's
August 1st whatever you're bringing me
Jordan's filming tick tocks now oh my
God obviously you just avoid the rice
and you can scoop it out of the mail off
you want but I mean I technically can
have the rice because I'm allowing
myself one carb a day and I haven't had
carbs yet then this girl just point out
how terrible her anti-carb lifestyle was
and here we are restricting ourselves to
a small serving of carbs every day folks
you can eat carbs and still be in a
calorie deficit in fact if having carbs
at meals makes your meals more
satisfying and enjoyable they will help
to reduce the need to snack between
meals or overeat at night honestly it
feels like Jaclyn's strict diet rules
are the reason she needs the other diet
rules I don't want to weigh myself every
single day because that's something that
I fell into and that was really really
bad because I would literally starve
myself at night like not starve myself
but I would have like a light dinner and
I wouldn't eat for like four hours five
hours before bed I would only drink
water and I'd be like I better wake up
in the morning and at least go down two
ounces and then I wouldn't and I'd be so
angry and it was just toxic I think I
should weigh myself once a week at least
we've done away with the daily weighing
and if you recall from one of my
previous reviews of Jaclyn's Journey the
daily weighing was such a strong trigger
for her so much so that it would send
her into an emotion spiral that would
trigger a binge and if the weekly Wing
is still triggering for her then I would
strongly suggest just getting rid of the
scale entirely and focusing on those
non-weight indicators of progress and
the only thing is I am going out of town
to see one of my best friends I have not
gone to see her in like two years since
before the pandemic so I'm leaving in
the middle of this month and while I'm
gone I will cheat like I will eat and
live my best did she not just talk about
how she felt living her best life while
she was just in Miami one sec let me
just rewind to make sure that I heard
that correctly this weekend we this last
week we went to Miami to celebrate my
birthday with some friends and we just
ate and drank the entire time I hate it
like I forget how bad it makes you feel
when you just eat like a plate of fried
food and just like oh the diarrhea the
stomach ache guys I was so nauseous at
one point in Miami I was this close to
throwing up yeah I'm still confused I'm
not saying she shouldn't enjoy her time
away with her best friend and live her
best life but by calling it a full out
cheat I have to assume that she's
drowning in the same scarcity mentality
that she just described as eating like
no carbs all week and then going Hog
Wild at a restaurant meal we can still
live our best lives without making
ourselves feel sick with excess and I
would argue that feeling sick all the
time from overeating is certainly not
living our best life it doesn't feel
good we don't feel like our best selves
but the first step in getting here is to
let go the diet mentality let go of the
strict rules and restriction and start
to give herself permission to enjoy all
the foods without guilt or shame again I
fully support folks who are on a weight
loss Journey but if we aren't in a good
starting place in a relationship with
food we are only going to end up going
back my more focus on like the results
and like now my thought is more like how
good can I feel how mentally clear can I
feel how sharp can I feel immensely
could not have done this a couple of
months ago absolutely I was incapable I
was so sad and anxious and depressed I
cried all the time I just craved comfort
food Jaclyn's words and actions are as
usual at odds her vocalized mindset
shift certainly sounds like she's made
some important strides but her actions
suggest that she's still stuck in the
depths of diet culture I'm definitely
interested to see how this rolls out and
of course I am staying hopeful that she
can find a path for her own aspirational
pep talk and behaviors can complement
each other and on that note that is all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
who or what you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to this Channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye foreign
[Music]